c'est le principal adversaire du tpm à
fort-de-france en 2014 la liste faut que
ça change et fo de france recueillait
8400 suffrages
34% des voix loin devant les autres
listes d'opposition
une fois encore le palima et ses alliés
s'appuient sur leur ancrage dans les
quartiers après 75 ans la forteresse
progressiste est toujours en place
francis carole pour la quatrième fois
candidat attend patiemment son heure
c'est vrai que le ppm n'a plus la
puissance de frappe qu'il avait avant
ayant perdu notamment la principale
collectivité et c'est vrai aussi que la
gestion actuelle est catastrophique
je savais dès le départ que la conquête
de la guilde aurait été difficile que ça
prendrait du temps des années parce
qu'ils avaient envie de gommer ces
erreurs dont des héritiers ne respecte
plus la passé et il fallait du temps
aujourd'hui nous considérons que le
travail que nous avons fait il suffit
d'un mois considérable désormais la
situation sur pétanque autrement la
liste palima mime cncp tendance les
hautains et martinique écologie s'appuie
sur la majorité territoriale pour mener
son combat
la victoire de francis carole et le
soleil avant de france doit être une
avancée non pas au fort de france
seulement mais pour la matinée
en marge de cette campagne municipale
impossible de ne pas interroger francis
carole conseiller exécutif en charge de
la santé sur les événements d'hier à
l'aéroport voici sa réponse je dis très
clairement que ce type de comportement
n'est pas productif et naoko noté m nous
ne sommes pas dans une lutte
pourquoi détruite qui vient la
martinique nous sommes en train de nous
battre pour protéger au maximum et
marquer et croix vd plus lancé des
pierres sur un coin sympa à ce qu'il
nous faut faire et je suis extrêmement
clair précis et ferme sur sa position
la liste faut que ça change et fo de
france et espère l élection dès le
premier tour
cette année cinq listes partagent la
même prétention